[Music]
[Music]
and I still achieve
[Applause]
[Music]
how's it going everybody so a lot of you
have been asking me to do a video on
this many of you have asked me is it
real is it fake a lot of you have
actually sent me the video itself asking
me to do a breakdown on it but sorry
everybody
it's fake but I'm also not sorry because
I hope that the first trailer that we do
get for Avengers 4 is nothing like this
this doesn't really show anything about
Avengers 4 and it also really doesn't
make much sense either
it shows the Infinity Gauntlet in the
beginning with no Infinity stones in it
and it's sort of steamy for whatever
reason that it may be and then you see
these statues of these three different
people and this doesn't make any sense
either this looks like Bucky and Captain
America fighting Iron Man and that
wouldn't be in a venture sport
especially not the trailer for it and
why would they put these sort of clay
statue type of things in the trailer it
just doesn't really make sense and then
you have the voiceover of someone who is
trying to sound like fan OHS it's
clearly not Josh Brolin who voices and
play Stannis and what he's saying
doesn't really make sense either he says
I had all the power and I still achieved
nothing it actually kind of sounds like
Arnold Schwarzenegger speaking and then
it says one last time May 2019 which is
also sort of an error there has been a
lot of talk lately that IMAX will
actually premiere a little bit earlier
than the regular screenings of Avengers
4 and it might actually end up being
released in April for IMAX so you
wouldn't put a definitive date in the
trailer so this is clearly fan-made
although the person that made this did
go to great depths to try to make it
seem like it was actually leaked it
seems like this person has some sort of
home theater and played it on their home
theater and recorded it and tried to
make it seem like it was being shown
somewhere and this person secretly
recorded it so kudos to the person who
made this for trying to be creative but
no way this is the trailer I mean look
at the first trailer that we got for
Avengers infinity war it was amazing it
showed all of the characters it showed
action it showed funny moments it was a
great teaser trailer it was awesome and
nothing like this but I get it the hype
around avengers' 4 is real thankfully
Kevin Feige just came out and said that
we will be getting the official trailer
for Avengers 4 before the end of the
year so sorry to burst your bubble if
you thought this was real it's not sorry
but let me know how excited you are to
finally get the real official trailer
for Avengers 4 also my giveaway still
continues giving away copies of infinity
war and ant-man and the wasp on blu-ray
and some special edition posters all you
have to do to enter is be subscribed to
my channel like this video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero as always thank you
all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]